the first speaker is gregory rosenthal
who will talk about
qac0 complexity of approximating party
okay uh can everyone see the slides
yes we see it okay thanks uh
yeah so uh so qac0 circuits are constant
depth quantum circuits
with arbitrary one cubit gates uh which
are pictured here as squares
and so-called generalized toefl gates uh
which
i take in an arbitrary number of control
qubits
and flip uh they act on the standard
basis by flipping the target qubit if
and only if all of the control qubits
are one
uh they're called they're basically like
uh and gates
and they're called generalized top
leagues because the
three qubit cases this is called a top
league um
or generally if you drop the superscript
zero we can also just talk about
qac circuits which are arbitrary depth
circuits of this form
other than just constant depth and qac
zero circuits are quantum analogs of
ac zero circuits uh ac zero circuits are
constant depth boolean circuits with end
and or gates of unbounded
fan in and not gates uh but it's
actually not
trivial for qac 0 circuits to simulate
ac 0 circuits
the reason for this is that ac0 circuits
are allowed
thin out for free meaning at no cost
they can create arbitrarily many copies
of the input bits
and of the outputs of gates whereas qac0
circuits are not granted this ability
axiomatically
so for quantum circuits to simulate fin
out we would like to compute the unitary
transformation pictured to the right
which acts on the standard basis by uh
flipping
all of the target qubits of which there
can be however many as we like
if and only if the control qubit is one
so then by feeding and still i
initialized to zero into the target
qubits
this allows us to create arbitrarily
many copies of any classical bit
and i want to stress that the bit b
being copied here is classical it's just
zero or one
not an arbitrary qubit otherwise this
would violate the no cloning theorem
so this raises the question is the final
transformation computable in qac zero
uh say we want to compute n qubit fan
out we would like to compute this in
size polynomial in
n but it's even an open question whether
it can be computed by
q a c 0 circuits of arbitrary size when
n is sufficiently large
and it's known that the fan ouch
transformation is equivalent to the
purity transformation
of the conjugation by hanmard gates so
the question of whether finn out is in
qac
0 is equivalent to the question of
whether parity is in qa c0
and remember we can't just simulate the
usual exponential size ac zero circuit
for purity to get an exponential size
uh qac zero circuit for a fan out
because again we can't just
simulate arbitrary ac zero circuits
directly in qa c0
and for comparison it's a famous result
in
classical circuit complexity that
exponential size is necessary as well as
sufficient to compute purity and ac 0.
and another reason why this question is
interesting is that polio meal sites qac
0 circuits can also compute
the majority function as well as
simulating ac 0.
so here's what's known about the qac 0
complexity of prd and finn out
we're going to go through these tables
line by line first i'm going to briefly
talk about the prior results for context
and then explain the results proved in
the current paper
and uh we only count multi-qubit gates
towards size and depth
uh just like uh in boolean circuit
complexity it's
customary to only count multi-qubit
gates towards size and depth
i.e uh boolean circuit complexity we
don't count not gates
that's what that means so uh first
there's a trivial log depth linear size
upper bound
as explained more precisely in the full
version of the talk
uh it it's also known that uh with
sublinearly many and still i super
constant depth is required
and it's known that uh when at the input
size n is sufficiently large
no depth to qac circuit of arbitrary
size can compute
a purity or fan out exactly and remember
we only count multi-qubit gates towards
size into depth here
so now in this paper we do four things
first we prove that
uh constant depth qac circuits can in
fact approximate
purity and thin out arbitrary well or
arbitrarily well
uh so uh the approximation perimeter
here
it's defined in the full version of the
talk uh here i'll just say that
it ranges between zero and one and it's
such that it's trivial to achieve a
one-half approximation of purity and fan
out
so for example in depth seven it takes
exponential size
more generally there's a size depth
trade-off similar to that of classical
ac zero circuits computing purity
uh then this first slower bound it's
explained more precisely in the full
version of the talk
here i'll just say that uh we introduce
a certain subclass of qac circuits that
generalizes the circuit from our upper
bound and we prove a tight lower bound
for this restricted subclass of qac
circuits
which means that new ideas are needed in
order to improve on the upper bound
uh then we prove that arbitrary qac
circuits of size
uh depth d and sides one-fifth times n
over d plus one and an
arbitrary number of van cili cannot
achieve much better than a one-half
approximation of parity
uh an interesting case of this result is
when d is theta of log n
because then this gives an omega n over
log n lower bound which nearly matches
the previously mentioned
log depth linear size upper bound
and finally we improved the previously
mentioned depth 2 lower bound to an
approximation lower bound
so all of these results are proof of
your reductions to a new problem that i
introduced uh that of constructing a
nekomoda state
or or something similar so
the cat's state for comparison is a
uniform superposition of the all
zeros in all one states uh this is a
well-known definition
uh and it's named this way because we
don't know whether the cat is alive or
dead
like schrodinger's cat so more generally
uh nekomata or two-tailed uh cat yokai
from japanese folklore
i also use uh named this uh certain
family of states after them because the
states side zero and psi one are kind of
like tails
uh so size zero one side one can be
arbitrary
states on an arbitrary number of qubits
and an equivalent definition of nekomata
is a states for which a standard basis
measurement of some n qubits
outputs all zeros with probability one
half and all ones with probability
one-half
so why are these states interesting in
one direction uh
given a circuit for thin out you can
construct the cat state as shown here
and in the full version of the talk i'd
take a brief moment to explain why
and in the other direction uh given a
circuit constructing a nekomata
you can compute purity as shown here and
in the full version of the talk i also
pause here to explain why
so now uh i'm just going to highlight
one of the proof techniques that i think
is both the most likely to be of
independent interest
it's a certain normal form for qyc
circuits
so for comparison it's known that in
classical
boolean circuits for simplicity here's a
formula we can push all of the not gates
to the bottom using the morgan's laws
like this
so we do something similar for quantum
circuits and for time's sake i'm going
to skip over all the intermediate
results
but the upshot is that you can write an
arbitrary quantum circuit as
a layer of one qubit gates adjacent to
the input
followed by a series of blocks where
each block is the conjugation of a
generalized
top league by a layer of one cubic gates
and
uh as it this is i'll explain a bit more
clearly in the full talk
i think but each block has a very
convenient i can decomposition
specifically
uh there's a single like eigenvec value
of minus one for which the corresponding
eigenvector is a product of one cubit
states
and all of the other eigenvalues are one
thank you
thanks
the next speaker is zachary ram scream
we'll talk about
lower bounds on the running time of
two-way
quantum finite automata and sub
logarithmic space qpms
great can people hear me and see my
slides
yes great
okay so let's start by talking about the
notion of quantum advantage
now as we all know quantum computers
seem to be more powerful than classical
computers perhaps the most
famous example of this apparent
advantage is given by the factoring
problem
where by peter shore's landmark result a
quantum computer can factor an integer
in polynomial time whereas certainly
there's no
known classical polynomial time
factoring algorithm
however it's certainly not the case
that quantum computers are some sort of
super machines that outperform classical
computers by some huge
margin on all problems with respect to
all computational resources
instead the more accurate statement is
that quantum computers
seem to be more powerful than classical
computers sometimes
for example consider the query
complexity of a total function
here it's known that quantum has the
most a polynomial advantage over
classical
and so this is a setting in which strong
limitations on quantum advantage
are known in this paper
we study the quantum advantage question
in the small space setting
and we prove tight limitations on the
degree to which quantum can outperform
classical in particular we give the
first example of a language
that can be recognized by a classical
algorithm in log space and polytime
for which no quantum algorithm can do
any better to recognize this language in
polytime
log space is needed and so this is an
example for which there is provably
no quantum advantage the
second example pertains to the finite
automata world
here we give the first example of a
language that no sort of classical 2a
finite automaton can recognize in
any time bound for which a to a finite
automaton can recognize an exponential
time
and for which exponential time is
provably needed
and so this second example gives us a
situation in which
quantum advantage approvally exists but
strong limitations on quantum advantage
can now be given
far more generally we introduce a new
technique
that can be used to lower bound the
quantum time space complexity
of any language and the above results
are just special cases
but before i say anything more about
these results
let me first spend a minute trying to
convince you that space
actually matters in quantum computation
now after several decades of progress
experimental quantum computers have
advanced to the point where we're now
in what john prescott calls the noisy
intermediate
scale era of quantum computation where
intermediate scale refers to the fact
these quantum computers have
few qubits for example consider a
current
state-of-the-art quantum computer ibm's
q system
which has 53 qubits
to put that number in perspective we can
compare this state-of-the-art quantum
computer with a
not at all state-of-the-art classical
computer apple's iphone 7
which has 128 gigabytes of memory
and has a retail cost of something like
400
now i don't know exactly how much
evidence q system cost to build i
imagine some sort of trade secret but i
think we'd safely assume it's a great
deal more than 400 dollars
of course this is a somewhat unfair
comparison
because when one says the iphone 7 has
128 gigabytes of memory that is
conflating together multiple different
kinds of memory
but the basic message is true
current and near-term quantum computers
have few cubits
they have a small amount of quantum
memory and so space
really is important in quantum
computation and
if you believe that then it's natural to
try to understand
what is the power of a quantum computer
that is only a small amount of space
we first focus on the extreme case of a
quantum computer that has only a
constant amount of space
which we model using finite autonomy
in particular we consider the two-way
quantum classical finite automaton
or 2q cfa as originally defined by
inbindus and watros
as follows we start with a 2dfa
that is a two-way deterministic binary
automaton
and we augment it with a quantum
register of constant size
we then allow the machine to interact
with this quantum register however it
likes
performing arbitrary unitary
transformations and arbitrary quantum
measurements
now in the same paper in which ambinus
and watrus first defined this model
they also exhibited two examples of
languages for which
2qcfa provably outperformed any sort of
classical finite dominant
the first such example was language leq
which consists of a run of zeros
followed by equal in front of once as
they showed
this language can be recognized by 2qcfa
in order n to the fourth time
and in recent paper i improved that to n
cubed time
of course one can help to do much better
as trivialist language can't be
recognized in little o n time
on the other hand it's known that note 2
dfa can recognize this language
in any time bound but to be completely
fair
we should also compare 2qcfa with 2pfa
to a probabilistic phytometer which are
two dfa that have been augmented with
the ability to flip coins
as probabilistic computation is a type
of classical computation
a 2pfa actually can recognize this
language
in exponential time but exponential time
is provably needed
there's a matching lower bound
the second example considered by bias in
waters was the palindrome language
which they showed can be recognized by
2qfa in
exponential time this is another example
of provable quantum advantage in the
constant space setting
as node 2 dfa or even 2 pfa can
recognize palindrome
in any time bound
but what about a lower bound for 2q cfa
can we do any better
is there a 2qcfa that recognizes
palindrome in sub-exponential time
maybe even in polynomial time as was the
case for leq
more generally is there any language
that can be recognized by 2qcfa in
exponential time
which we can prove can't be recognized
in sub-exponential time
or at least not in polynomial time
these were all open questions which we
resolved in this paper
in particular we prove that no you can't
do any better than the original minus
watch russ construction
no 2qcfa can recognize palindrome in
sub-exponential time
where we emphasize that this is the
first example of a language
that provably requires exponential time
on a 2q cfa
now this example for palindrome is
merely a special case of a far more
general result
namely for any language l we establish a
lower bound on the running time of any
2qcfa that recognizes l
to be precise we show this running time
grows at least as fast as the
non-regularity of l
raised to the power of some constant b
where non-regularity is a particular
hardness measure of a language that was
originally defined by dwark and
stockmeyer
if we then consider the particular case
of palindrome we
obtain the exponential time lower bound
to mention on the previous slide
now the results states so far apply to
quantum funded automata which are just
quantum computers that have only a
constant amount of space
more generally we have a lower bound on
the running time of any quantum computer
that uses a sub-logarithmic amount of
space
where now this lower bound is expressed
in terms of both the non-regularity of
the language and the amount of space we
allow the machine to use
lastly just to find a bit of context for
our lower bound we compare it to the
analogous result proven by dwarf and
stockmeyer for 2pfa
namely as they showed the running time
of any pfa
is lower bounded by an exponential in
their hardest measure
where we emphasize that both of these
lower bounds are essentially tight
that is the dork stockmar lower bound
for 2pfa is exponentially stronger than
our lower bound for 2q cfa
however this exponential difference
can't be helped
this is just yet another example of a
situation which quantum computers
exponentially outperform classical
computers
way thank you for listening
the next stock is time space lower
bounds for proof systems with quantum
and randomized verifiers
by abhijit modigonda and ryan williams
uh hello everyone i'm abigail and i'll
be talking about our paper
time space lower months for simulating
proof systems with quantum and
randomized verifiers
this is joint work with ryan williams at
mit uh for starters
what is the time space lower bound well
let x be either a specific problem or a
set of problems so a complexity class
our goal is to show that x or a problem
and x can't be solved by algorithms
they're simultaneously fast and use
small space
and the robin complexity class here is
tsn to the c which is
uh the language is decidable by random
access machines that you simultaneously
enter the little oven space and o event
of the sea time so
with this in mind here's an example of a
time space where i found and it's due to
ryan williams and o7
sat the satisfiability problem is not
contained in ts and to the c
is c is less than about 1.801 so really
this is saying that there's no random
access machine
that can solve sat on n-bit inputs in
say log space and end to the 1.8 time
and all the main results in this talk
are going to be essentially of this form
they're all going to say
some problem in x cannot be solved by a
y machine that uses small space
and o of n to the c time if c is less
than z for
suitable x y and z so
the other part of the title was proof
systems of quantum and randomized
verifiers and
by that we're really referring to
certain complexity classes
uh uh you're probably mostly familiar
with np which is uh those languages
whose yes instances have classical
proofs which can be verified in
polynomial time by a deterministic
verifier
so this is their approver they're
progressing the classical proof
to a deterministic verifier with some
verifies in polynomial time
uh so this is this is what we call a
proof system with the deterministic
verifier
so then a proof system of the randomized
verifier gives us the
corresponds to the complexity class m a
or merlin arthur
and if they make the verified quantum
then they get qcma or
quantum classical maryland arthur and
qcma is the complexity class that we're
going to focus on in this talk
all right so uh let's start with one of
our results uh
theorem one linear time qcma on a qram
or qcma time n is not in ts and to the c
for c less than about two point three
six six and what do we mean by linear
time q say may on a qram
well i mentioned that qcma is
corresponds to proof systems with
quantum verifiers and
here we mean that our quantum verifier
runs on a quantum random access machine
so that's the computational model
and it runs in time linear in the length
of the input and
qcma time n the complexity class of
language is decidable by such machines
cannot be solved by say log space
omen to the 2.36 time random access
deterministic random access machines
and this is like a quantum version of
the existing classical work on which is
due to williamson o7
uh non-deterministic linear time on a
ram or end time of n
is knocking tsn to the c for c less than
about 1.801
so basically we give a qcma time version
of an existing end time lower bound and
concurrently our lower bound experiment
is larger
than is provable in the classical
setting and both theorems are obtained
via the method of quantifier trading
proofs
so how do those work well at a high
level quantified trading proofs
are composed of alternating complexity
classes which are
fine-grained versions of levels of the
polynomial hierarchy
and an example of this is existing
squared
for all n to the 0.3 ts n to the fifth
we're really just saying on an n bit
input the existential quantifier is
restricted to a guess
of a length n squared the universal
quantifier is restricted to a gas of
length into 0.3
and the verification procedure at the
end takes n to the fifth time
so now a quantified trading proof is
just a conditional sequence of
inclusions of such alternating
complexity classes
and we have two ways of showing such
inclusions we have speed up rules which
add quantifiers and reduce the overall
runtime so
for example we can show inclusions like
tsn squared it's contained in
exists n for all log n tsn and you can
see that there's
two new quantifiers on the right hand
side of this inclusion but the
uh verifier the runtime of the
verification procedure has decreased
from owen square to o1
and we also have slow down rules which
conditionally remove quantifiers and
increase runtime
uh so for example assuming cohen time n
in tsn to the c we can show that exists
then
for a log n t s n is contained in exists
n t s n to the c
so we've removed a quantifier but the
runtime is increased o and c is greater
than one i guess
so given stronger assumptions in this
slowdown rule we can prove stronger
inclusions and
what we're going for is to prove
impossible inclusions inclusions that
violated him hierarchy theorem because
this actually means that
our assumption must have been false so
this this allows us to falsify
assumptions that we make and get a proof
by contradiction
uh and it turns out that uh if we start
with tsn to the d
apply the speed up and slow down rules
in various ways and orders
and ultimately show that ts enter the d
is contained in tsn to the d prime
for d prime less than t this implies a
contradiction we don't have a ts higher
here anything but it contracts uh the
non-deterministic time hierarchy here as
it turns out
so uh an important thing to note here is
that the speeder portal produces small
quantifiers so over
over all log in this and this will be
useful later
cool so the main technical tool we
introduced in this work is the generic
slowdown rule
so i mentioned slow down rules are
quantifier removing rules generic slot
and rules are
solid rules associated some additional
parameter alpha
which is between zero and one and we can
show conditional inclusions like exists
n
for all login tsn is contained in exists
in
ts end to the alpha c and the sloan rule
in previous work was generic with alpha
equals one hence the name
the idea is that we can prove stronger
inclusions if our assumption gives us a
generic slowdown rule with a smaller
value of alpha since as you can see
the right hand side of the inclusion
gets tighter as uh alpha decreases
so an actual question is suppose some
assumption gives us a generic solution
rule with a parameter alpha
what's the lower bound that we get and
uh we can ask you that
if x is a complexity class and the
theorem x
in t s n to the c implies a generic
split under rule of parameter alpha
then we have a lower bound on x uh x is
not in tsn
to the c so x can't be solved by small
space n to the c
rams if c is smaller than the largest
due to some polynomial
uh that depends on alpha so as a
corollary previous work on end time of n
used a slow down rule with alpha equals
one which gives the which
when applied theorem gives x cubed minus
x squared minus two s plus one
and the largest root of this is turns
out to be two cosine pi over seven and
that's where that weird number that's
one way to see where this weird
whenever it comes from and this implies
the end time lower bound from
past work so now the goal is to apply
this theorem when x is qcma time n
and we hope to get a generic slowdown
with the smaller alpha from the stronger
assumption because this implies
stronger lower bounds uh
so the way we do this in the quantum
setting is by using grouper's algorithm
and in particular generic slot and rules
are quantifier removing operations and
quantifiers can be thought of as
stretching searching for the right
string
or a wrong string because basically
they're asking things like does there
exist
a string of length m which satisfies
blah
so cloning computers can actually
perform search quickly using gerber's
algorithm and if you aren't familiar
with gerber's algorithm it basically
lets us stretch your database and n
items and o of root on time
uh so the key idea here is we can use
gerges algorithm to remove small
quantifiers
and by working with this logic a bit we
can get a generic slot on rule small
alpha and the quantum setting so
putting everything together uh it turns
out that the assumption qcma time n
nps end to the c yield the general
solution rule parameter alpha equals two
thirds
from earlier we had this theorem that
tells us what the lower bound we get
from a given generic slot on rule is and
so plugging alpha equals two-thirds into
this theorem we get that key same a time
n is not in ps into the c
for c less than about two point three
six six and that's term one
uh we also have some other lower bounds
against probabilistograms
uh that i won't go into in the interest
of time but uh
one of their improves resulted in scott
deal and the other one is uh
new i guess cool
uh that's all folks
thanks
and the next stock is self-testing
of a single quantum device under
computational assumptions by tony medgar
and thomas
all right thank you can you see
everything into everything
yes yeah all right excellent and yeah so
thank you this is
drink work with somebody and for the
purposes of this short introduction
instead of this official title i want
you to think of a much broader question
and that is how much control can a
classical efficient verifier
exert of an untrusted prover so verifier
and prover here refers to the setting of
interactive proof systems and in the
setting we have some
classical polytime entity called
verifier
who can by classic communication
interact with this
untrusted prover and it means that when
the verifier asks the approver to
perform some computation for her
she can't be sure that the result that
the approver reports back is actually
the correct
answer so traditionally in the setting
this prover here is computationally
unbounded so can decide
any language and the goal of the
verifier is to find out the answer to
some computational problem
and it's been known for a long time that
this is in fact possible as long as the
problem is in p
space now i want to look at this from a
different perspective and that is
i want to ask you how much control does
this give the verifier over the approver
and the answer is well not so much
because
all the verifier can really say is that
if the approver tries to
convince her of an incorrect answer to
the computational problem
then the verifier will catch this as
cheating behavior
but this doesn't give the verifier any
control over what's going on inside
the prover so what we're interested in
is
here is can we give the verifier some
leverage
not just over the validity of the
results here but also over the means by
which the prover computes these results
internally
so to do that we need to we can't just
have a computationally unbounded prover
we need to
bound this prover somewhat and it turns
out that a useful way of finding this
prover is to say
that it's a polytime quantum computer so
now
this is essentially the setting of
quantum cloud computing where you have
some classical
client the classical internet and then
some untrusted
quantum server so how far
have we have we gotten in this quest for
controlling
quantum provers well the setting was
introduced in in two papers the first by
mahadev on verification of quantum
computation
and this is a really great paper but
from the
point of view of the verifier trying to
control the inner workings of this
approver
this doesn't get us much more than just
the interactive proofs from the previous
slide
the other paper that introduced this is
by recursion others
and what they showed is that in this
interaction
the verifier can actually certify that
the provers
answers must contain a certain amount of
information theoretic
randomness and if you think about it
this is kind of a remarkable
result because you can't just look at a
string and be like well that's random
you actually need to certify that the
process by which that string was
generated
must have produced some randomness so
this means
that in this protocol the verifier must
know
that whatever quantum operation the
prover used to compute
the answers here this quantum operation
must necessarily
you know produce some randomness that
the verifier can then extract
so here i also want to highlight that
you know this this computational
assumption here the point of it
is not to make the verifier more
efficient or something
it's really to do things like this to be
able to say something about the
inner workings of this which allows us
to certify
things that we just can't certify in
this standard interactive proof setting
now the third item in our little story
here
is due to georgie and vidic and what
they showed is that
in fact you can go further and the
verifier can certify that the approver
has prepared a certain single qubit
quantum state
so here the verify can actually make
like a pretty meaningful statement
about the state space of this untrusted
approver
and our result builds on on these and
what we show is that you know we can go
further still so we give a protocol that
allows the verifier to certify
that the approver must have prepared an
epr state which is
this quantum state up to normalization
and measure the two qubits in this epr
state individually
so the reason why we are interested in
this epr state and
single qubit measurements in particular
is because this epr state is a maximally
entangled state
so by this protocol the verifier can
really certify
that this single quantum prover here
must have produced some entanglement
internally so a bit more
detail the structure of this protocol is
that we have some
setup rounds that involve some use of
first quantum crypto like previous works
and in this last round of interaction
the verifier sends over a challenge
and receives back some answer and the
guarantee that we're able to prove
is that if the prover succeeds in this
protocol with high probability so
passes all of the checks that the
verifier applies
then to answer the verifiers challenge
in this last round
the approver must have performed single
qubit measurements on an epr state
and i want to stress here that this must
have performed single qubit measurements
on an epr state
is really a physically meaningful
statement this really means that the
prover must have prepared a physical
epr state so in particular you know
single qubit measurements and epr states
that's easy to simulate classically you
might think you can even do that on
paper
but the protocol really certifies that
there is a physical epr state present in
here
and the proverb can't just simulate this
classically to get out of this
so one advantage of being able to show
that you know this is a real epr state
is that we can based on this build a
protocol for something else called
device independent quantum key
distribution
so this is follow-up work with these
co-authors and
i won't have time to explain this in
much detail
but in the language i've been using so
far the basic intuition
is that you know this prover is now
somehow very long and stretched out
with classical parties that either end
who can only publicly communicate
and even though they can't trust this
prover they are nonetheless able to
extract private information
theoretically secure keys from this
now another brief comment i want to make
is that this kind of state certification
actually has a name
it's called self-testing and this was
known previously but in an entirely
different setting where you have
two provers who may be entangled but
can't communicate
so from this point of view you can also
view our result as
taking this kind of self-testing
statement but then collapsing down
these two provers into one and getting
rid of this non-communication assumption
here
right so i want to end with an open
problem which is probably the the
natural open problem at this point
and that is can we push this this quest
for controlling quantum improvers even
further so
can we certify a larger class of states
than just epr pairs in this setting
all right i'll end here thank you
the last speaker is the last stock is
distributed quantum
proofs for replicated data by
pierre franio francois
karumichi nishimura and ami paz
thank you i'll have to share my screen
just a minute
hello so yes i'm ami paz as i mentioned
and this is john hockett pierre franio
francois
and our mission in shimura about
distributed computing and using
quantum bits for distributed
verification
so the kind of questions the specific
question we talk about
in this work is the replicated data
problem we have a network
and some of the units of the network
called terminals
have data in them and we want to make
sure that all the replicas of the data
are the same
we have many data centers that should
keep relic of the same data i want to
make sure while running other processes
on the network
that the replicated data is indeed
replicated as the same
all the copies are the same very
basic problem and
we use mechanisms of distributed
certification these are mechanisms that
allow us to check
properties of a system of a network
basically with small computation small
communication in the background
so these are known as proof leveling
schemes locally checkout proofs and
recent work
coined the term of distributed
interactive proofs or distributed
mailing article
proofs what we present in this work is
distributed quantum media to proofs
and this is what i'll describe for you
now so the base for all these kind of
mechanisms
is the following we have a system at
this network
and there is one prover it sees all the
system and tries to help us
help the units of the system to verify
the state this is the prover
and all the other nodes of the graph or
units in the system
are verifiers so many of many very first
not just one
and their goal is to verify the state of
the system they replicate the data in
this case
by communicating to another so we have
two phases the first
phase the approver gives certificates to
the verifiers to the
nodes of the system and they may
disappear and not be part
and in the second phase the units of the
system the
verifiers exchange messages specifically
they will exchange just the certificates
so each node of the graph or unit
network
change certif exchange certificate with
their neighbors
do some computation and answers if you
think the state is okay
duplicate data are the same or not what
we want is that
to check if there's a way to assign
certificates
such that if all the replicas are
identical that all nodes accept
everybody say everything's okay
and we can reuse this certificate again
and again to verify
later on that the replica data is still
okay that nothing went wrong
and if they're not all identical at some
point something goes wrong one of the
replicas goes corrupted
then at least one of the nodes must
reject
at least one realize an arm says
something is wrong we have to recompute
re-replicate the data and have new
certificates
what are these certificates how do we
get them to start with so it's just a
string
basically and we say okay we build a
network
so give each of the units some auxiliary
information that allows us to check the
state of the system durability data in
this case
and another way to think of it is has
external
entity is this prover or google cloud it
sees all the network help the units to
verify something
but you don't trust it completely or
it's not always there so you have to
verify yourself later on
the state of the system and they
replicated it and our goal in this work
in many other talks in the field
is to have very small certificates
actually every problem is
verifiable with the size of the network
squared
with the south network a certificate of
size the data certificate
so getting polynomial size certificates
is easy
what we want is much smaller like
logarithmic size certificate or
constant size certificates
and this is what we will do today
so why do we care about distributed
certification
checking properties of a network so
first of all it has practical results
and there are many practical works
mainly on verifying
states of network to check for faults
and other works another perspective is
more theoretical perspective because
this is actually
an analog of np or of non-deterministic
computation
in the distributed setting the
certificate here is just the end
witness of the answer to a problem
and the new thing in our work is using
quantum bits
both as certificates and as messages so
our certificate is quantum certificate
as the messages are quantum messages
so what we show what we do in this work
first of all is to define this mechanism
of distributed
quantum medial to proofs we give a
distributed quadrant error to
protocol for the replicated data
problems i mentioned in the beginning
where the size of the certificates and
messages in all
is only logarithmic in the size of the
data here
n is the surface data not the size of
the network
okay so we think of very large data kept
in some places in the network and we
want to have very small certificates
compared to the size of this of the data
sorry
and finally we show that any distributed
mailing out of protocol that doesn't use
quantum bits
will require linear size certificates or
messages
and this is true even if we can use the
random
anonymization so the classical
mechanisms will decide will require c
a linear size
and so how do we do this if we had only
two terminals in the network
just two units that are neighbors that
have to check the
replicated data this can be very easy we
know this for communication complexity
we just use a random hash function and
hash the
data that you need is a classical
solution
but we cannot do the same in this
state of a bigger network say even just
the path network as in this example
because we cannot choose the hash
function trando
because we don't interact with the
prover and we cannot trust approval to
give a such function because it may
pick a specific hash function that
causes a collision
so what we do instead is having a
quantum fingerprint as certificate
and as messages and this is actually a
superposition
of many hash functions and the hashes of
their replicated data under these
hash functions so this will be the
certificate
and then the node will exchange these
certificates
uh to check in order to verify them
and check that they are all the same and
that the hash or sorry the quantum
fingerprint
of each of the inputs is the same as the
certificate that is
common to all the units
so this is the idea there are some
challenges like checking the equality of
quantum states
or the fact that you cannot clone this
quantum state you cannot keep one for
uh to check it with the message you get
and send the quantum state that you got
the certificate
because you cannot clone the and we
cannot keep replica of this
certificate other problems have to do
with using the states for verification
and because we want to verify again and
again but you don't want to
stay to collapse and finally what
happened if your state is not even a
product state as i mentioned before
but totally corrupted can you still
check their quality and get
meaningful results and the way of
answering some of these challenges
is by using a swept test specifically
this will allow us to check that the
final print
is the same if the inputs are the same
the frames will be the same with
probability one
otherwise with much lower probability
and by repeating we can make sure that
we accept only its very low probability
we also make sure that the quantum state
does not collapse
as long as the freemium pit is in of the
same
input so as long as everything is okay
in the system
you can you can reuse the quantum states
the certificates again and again
and finally if you get a very much very
corrupted quantum state that is not even
a product it will still have this
properties that i mentioned
in the beginning of the slide and we can
apply the test as usual other challenges
i will not talk about today
or in the recorded talk as with general
grass and not just the path
as with whatever when you have more than
two terminals
and with proving lower bounds and
specifically the roman dimension for the
non-quantum
they said and i will finish here just
say that
the main idea here is that we get
exponential advantage
for this quantum computation with
respect to
uh distributed non-quantum computation
and certification
sorry and open problems to use the same
ideas for other problems like triangle
freeness and symmetry important problems
in
networks and proving lower bounds for
quantum verification
and we'll stop it thank you very much
thanks
and now we have time for discussion so
this
can either involve questions about talks
or more general discussion on
quantum computing
um i have a question for ami yes please
about the talk that just happened
uh yeah i was wondering what is the size
of the
so you have like some over like eight
some that you have a summer like h and
then hx right
is that like your your certificate
states
like how how large are the like
how uh how large is the second
the second term in the product
here yeah i think you balance them to be
more is the same you need
encoding of the hash function and then
you need a hashing
of the input that you get
okay i think they are both logan if i
remember correctly
oh i i see okay and okay and then
so you get like inverse polynomial you
get like one half plus poly
error yet like one versus like one half
plus polynomial one half plus one every
polynomial in there
is that what happens or what their
probability
yeah i i will have to check i don't
really remember over the top of my head
but the idea is that you can really
repeat this in parallel
many times without paying much more
so you can okay that makes sense thank
you
okay
um i have a question for abhijit
um do you think we can
extend the what we're doing with the
slowdown rules and speed up rules
uh in order to to try to separate uh
space classes from uh time classes but
in the other direction like
polynomial space from uh criminal time
because uh
when you when we think of polynomial
space we may be able to remove
a lot of quantifiers at the same time
because you know
the piece based complete problem qbf
can have an arbitrary number of
classifiers
so do you think we could we could use a
slow down rule
of this kind assuming like p space
belongs to uh
to linear time to remove a lot of
controls at the same time
yeah it's an interesting idea the main
difficulty there is you wouldn't have a
corresponding speed up rule
so the speed up rules which we didn't
discuss because of the
short time um they
really rely on having a small space
bound
in the algorithm like a really small
space like a logarithmic or
in the level of one space down
okay but yeah yeah there you can
imagine having a speed up of generic
time like
the speed up would actually be a space
efficient simulation
so like one can show that um linear
space is not in
little o of n log n time um
by using this hop crop pollen valence
uh simulation of time t in space
t over log t for example
so there are there are theorems that do
something like this but
the speedup rules aren't nearly as nice
i have a question to the last speaker i
guess ami
uh sorry if i'm mispronouncing your name
um
i i just wanted uh i wasn't that
familiar with this area but there is
something similar
sounding in cryptographic community and
i just want to make sure
if it is similar or not so in your
models is different
i guess servers that stores the data um
they're trusted in a sense that
somebody basically you have like a bunch
of servers that have the date and
you just want you assume server owners
but maybe one of the servers just
accidentally
got the wrong data or something like
that or
for example does your system protect
again as the following behavior that
maybe
uh i know there are five servers only
one of them stores the data
but maybe the other folder erase the
data but this one server maybe helps out
those
four servers um and then they full uh i
guess
they will pass this test so in other
words
do you have a guarantee that there are
really five
distinct copies of the same data or it's
assume some kind of
on a setting where you just worry about
the data
just accidentally go getting corrupted
or something
so i thought you said in the end we
assume that the servers are
totally reliable i mean are totally
honest
maybe their memory is not reliable but
they're honest and try to
verify the data the approver may not be
reliable
but the servers are all reliable
so this is very different i know if
you're familiar well just also
if you are you can take a look at some
of the recent papers i think we had some
paper tcc and another paper at crypt
where it's really the problem where you
really want to make sure that the
servers are really replicating your data
so you're saying your results don't
apply but uh i guess if you find it
interesting
i guess you can take a look at this uh
it looks like stronger setting where the
serosa maliciously trying to
claim that they back up your data with
redundancy but they really don't
uh i don't know just a suggestion maybe
yes yes it's definitely irrelevant and
interesting
but it's different from our setting yes
and then i i have maybe i guess if i
take this floor so
a very quick question i guess to uh
against tony uh in the pre in the world
uh the talk the ones before
uh i just looked at the abstract it
appears that
you're saying you rely on some of the
techniques introduced by these previous
papers
uh like by brachiarsky tal and so on
uh what is different is your protocol
uh just cleaner and simpler
or because there i know they certify
randomness uh
those protocols and uh but you do more
uh i'm just trying to see what is the
difference from those works
why can't we just directly use those
papers right so they
the the burkisky one gets randomness
which is
so you basically show that you have two
measurements which are somewhat
incompatible and the clergy vidic one
gets one qubit
so what we get is an epr pair which is
well a two qubits
and going from one to two is is much
less trivial than it sounds in this case
because you need to prove a certain like
parallel repetition type thing and
secondly
this two qubit set is entangled which
they also didn't get before so
those are the the two main differences
these things like
the basic problems the output is kind of
more powerful so some say
uh so essentially your applications
cannot be
immediately achieved by the application
you know by the technique
for example right so for example this
device independent quantum key
distribution that i mentioned at the end
this is something that you can only get
from certifying epr pests that you can't
get from just
certifying you know randomness or single
qubits
so i guess that's like the the prime
example of an application that we can
get from
this stronger certification protocol
that you can't get from the previous
ones
you think you know uh in just in terms
of if uh
can somebody directly read your paper or
you need to read all three to get into
this area
well i mean we've tried to write it in a
way that you can read it directly
um but i'll give you the judge as to
whether we we succeeded so
the idea is that you can read it
directly yeah thanks
hi uh uh hi i had a
query for uh uh abhijit uh uh
so uh uh how are you applying uh
groovers algorithm for the uh um
disentangled qubits since those bits are
in a flux
so i know uh
grooves algorithm in a
two-bit state but uh how are you
extending it here
um what do you mean by disentangled
cubits exactly
uh since the rules are in a flux so
uh uh with respect to the constant
change
is there some sort of intermediate uh
representation
from which you are probably uh
sampling those uh
qubits so
i was just confused uh so as to
how they are those flux states
are being uh used in those
uh groover state
maybe um i think maybe i think maybe
i'm not sure if this exactly answers
your question but i think the right way
to think about this is that
we're using it to like uh invert
we obviously have like like a quantifier
is essentially like a classical function
so like
and like we're just searching over the
possible inputs to the classical
we're essentially searching over the
inputs of the classical function all
right the quantifier is acting sort of
like a classical function and we're
basically
searching over the inputs and so there's
nothing that's like
yeah and uh yeah and so like in that
sense like it's not
there's no like sampling or like
anything fancy going on in that regard
like we just have like this we're we're
searching we're searching through the
like input table of a classical function
in some sense
um the only maybe the subtlety that like
you're catching that uh
i didn't address in the talk is that
like this is like part of why we need to
use it right really the reason we need
to use a
qram as opposed to this like the uniform
circuit model is because
we need to be able to like the
we want to improve lower bands against
random access machines and so
we need and in order for in order to
apply grover's algorithm
in our setting we also need the quantum
computer to be able to simulate
random access in some sense that's why
we use quantum rep that's why our model
of computation is the quantum random
access machine
i don't think the second part is exactly
what you're asking but maybe the first
part is
so the um with respect to the second
part
it's a fully um deterministic
system so those uh
gone sorry yeah just i
needed to uh clarify for my point of
view
since you're uh taking those uh
uh values from those uh predefined
uh environmental states so it's a fully
deterministic system um
i wouldn't say it's a fully
deterministic system but i just meant
that there's no like
there's no like sampling from a
distribution or anything like that and
in the process like we just like we have
a function and
we want to like we want we have we have
some function and we want to invert it
and that's all that's really good thank
you
so what are the natural complexity
classes right above qacz
classically above ac 0 we have acc
what are the natural classes about qac0
quantum league
good question so a natural one is to add
thin out gates
and then we know that it includes
classical tc0
and i'm not sure what the known upper
bound is on qac 0 within out kids
okay thanks the next session is starting
in the other seminar room in
two minutes but
we can stay here and keep keep
discussing
maybe to follow up on that question so i
guess what is like the
strongest quantum complexity class that
we can prove like
circular bounds for like strong circular
bands is it
q a c zero as far as you know uh yeah as
far as i know
just because because we don't know how
to prove classical lower bounds for tc
zero so we can't totally prove lower
bounds for q a
zero with fan now okay but okay
yeah and even for qyc 0 we only have
lower bounded limited special cases
yeah hi uh uh so uh uh follow-up
the approximations with respect to the
max of uh the cardinality of the
dot product of the v and c uh
i think it's the l squared norm
uh over the
mata so i was just confused there could
you please
uh explain that uh how those
approximations are being
uh sampled oh uh sure so
uh the uh definition of approximation i
used for constructing the nekomata
um so the mag magnitude
squared of the inner product between
some nekomata
and whatever state you've constructed so
for the upper bounds you can make this
uh
magnitude squared close to one for the
lower bounds it can't be uh much better
than one half regardless of the nekomata
you choose
so uh this will uh the upper bound is
for some specific nekomata not an
arbitrary nekomata
oh cool yeah but it doesn't
in terms of the reduction from purity to
nekomata it doesn't matter which
nekomata you construct
okay so uh and those gates can be scaled
as well with respect to uh
those uh up upper bound uh
if uh let me rephrase my query
so i was uh wondering uh this
mega mata is mostly a classical circuit
uh can we have some sort of uh
argumentation that can be done and
will that upper bound scale according to
that
uh oh yeah so the way i s are you
talking asking me how i scale the upper
bound to higher depth
yeah that's the question yes so yeah do
it just like uh
in the classic so like uh for classical
circuits computing parity the way that
skills to higher depth
so that like uh so you have d layers of
n to the one over d qubit purity gates
uh with that you can
compute n cubit parity by just uh
chaining together lots of sub
computations
so i do the same thing in uh this paper
which is why we get that
similar size depth trade off
so yeah so the way i construct nekomata
in the higher depths is by reducing the
parity and higher depth which is done by
reducing the purity and lower depth
which is done by constructing a nakamoto
and lower depth
yeah thanks yeah you're welcome
there's also a question for army pass
by one of the nd sim q a
where is exponential quantum advantage
is it in the speed of
verifying where does that speed up come
from
also other improvements in the one time
initialization or the size of the
certificates
there was no issue of timing of this
work the only issue we care about
is the size of certificate both because
we have to keep them in all the units
and because we have to send them in the
verification process
and that venue is getting the
certificates much smaller
in logarithmic size in the center of the
data instead of linearity
of the data so that's where that
scientist comes
the computation is marginal usually in
our
in theory of communication networks we
think of the
communication has taken much longer and
much more complicated than the local
computation
so that's where it comes
i had a practical query uh suppose uh
uh all those uh
files or the uh documents that that we
have
will need to be in the memory uh for
a faster uh qubit uh algorithmic hash
function that has to be
calculated based on the
certificate that has to be provided so i
was just wondering
uh since currently the bottleneck here
is with respect to the uh
[Music]
those databuses
in the practical scenarios how do you
achieve to implement it
such that this bottleneck doesn't come
into play
well as you can expect we didn't really
implement this
so it's not uh it's not clear we didn't
look
and we didn't look at the local
computation at all as i just mentioned
so we didn't care about this
this kind of problem it may be real
probably in practice but
the main question we were carrying about
was can you reduce the communication
and the size of the certificate you have
to keep in memory not the other
local computation you do
that's the common practice in
distributed computing actually you look
about
the communication and the interaction
between the units and not what happened
inside each unit that is
negligible hmm yeah well with respect to
that uh
yeah that that could be yeah it will
still uh there will be that bottleneck
so i was
thinking of uh in a whole distributed
system how can we architect that
uh too completely okay thanks got it
sure
i'll be moving to the next room and i
guess it's time to close the session
anyway
so thank you